uh let me just take you to Kigali where
we can show you the Home Secretary
swella bravaman walking down the steps
there as she lands in Rwanda the Home
Secretary there to meet officials and
reinforce the government's plans to try
and Deport migrants who arrive in the UK
by small boat or other illegal means to
Rwanda of course none of the deportation
flights that the government had planned
have actually left the UK yet to go to
Rwanda held up under legal challenge but
the Home Secretary is arriving in Rwanda
today as you can see meeting officials
there to look at the facilities that
have been laid on to accommodate the
people that the British government would
plan to send there in the event that
those legal challenges amidst the
government has of course one is licked
his legal case to say that their policy
is illegal